(upbeat music)
I was trying to save the world.
I was trying to, you know,
make all this money,
do all this stuff to go out and proselytize
and tell everybody how they needed to behave.
I've really come to terms with how important it is
that I take personal responsibility for myself
and I take ownership of how I am.
(upbeat music)
I want you to imagine a scenario in which suddenly all
of your fantasies come true.
You awake as this young man to discover
that you're being massively rewarded
for living a life of just extraordinary overindulgence.
Well, if you're lucky,
you also awake on a later date to realize that this life,
your life, a life so many aspire to a life of sex, drugs,
and rock and roll and wealth and fame,
a life you are absolutely convinced would make you happy
instead leaves you empty, but also motivated to evolve,
to embark on a sort of Viktor Frankl-esque
search for meaning.
That ultimately provokes a spiritual awakening
and a path towards purpose,
greater self-actualization and ultimately service.
This is a story that has recurred on this show
in many forms,
but today's version of that story
comes in the shape of Adrian Grenier.
You know Adrian as an actor,
he's appeared in a multitude of films
and television projects, but of course,
most well-known for his portrayal of Vinny Chase
in "Entourage,"
which was this dizzying and quite meta experience
that came to parallel his own life.
But Adrian has now evolved past this archetype
of adolescent id,
trading Hollywood for a ranch outside Austin,
maturing into a regenerative farmer and an environmentalist,
an impact investor,
and a man who cares deeply about our symbiosis with self,
with each other and the natural habitat we share.
Today, he shares his story and it's a good one.
So please hit that subscribe button
and enjoy my conversation with Adrian Grenier.
Well, first of all, happy birthday, man.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I appreciate you inviting me
to your birthday party last night.
I'm sorry I couldn't make it.
I didn't get the email until too late, but...
Who emails birthday invitations?
I don't know.
We should have texted you.
It's cool, man.
We should have called you
It's cool man.
But happy birthday.
Thank you.
How old are you now, 44?
45.
45, yeah.
You're a man.
Yes, officially.
You're a middle age officially.
Yeah.
How does it feel?
Good.
I just grew up fast enough to squeeze in manhood,
within the 45 years.
Had I waited another year
I'd probably would've never grown up.
Yeah well, I feel like you've been on this crash course.
You've compressed a lot into the last couple of years,
which is what we're going to get into.
Yeah.
What's funny,
well, thank you for making time to do this today.
It's super nice to finally meet you.
And what's funny about
the fact that we're sitting here today
is that we were first introduced,
we talked about this on the phone the other day.
I don't know if you recall,
but we were first introduced by Mishkishi Bally
back in December of 2015.
And we had some back and forth on email.
Mm-hmm, yeah I remember.
And that didn't seem to go anywhere.
And then like, I feel like every year and a half or so,
you'd resurface
and we try to figure out how to sit together
and then we just couldn't sync it up.
So you are officially the longest gestating podcast guest
in the, this has taken six years to make happen,
but I've learned to not force these things.
Like they're meant to happen when they're meant to happen.
Yeah.
And I feel like had you had we done this in 2016,
it would be very different and far less meaningful.
I don't think I had anything interesting to say back then.
Maybe a few things.
But I feel like now you're in a position to talk about
a lot of important meaningful things.
Yeah, well, you know, so back then,
I had a lot more people between me
and guys like you.
Yeah, I gathered as much.
There were a lot of gatekeepers.
A lot of gatekeepers.
So a lot of this stuff didn't even get to me
and I willfully remained ignorant 'cause you know,
I didn't want to have to work too much.
You know, it's like if I didn't, if my people didn't call me
and tell me I had to do something
all the better, 'cause I can go to brunch.
Sure.
And then I went through a period
where I just shed everything
and was doing nothing because I was basically in isolation.
And now I'm sort of finding a nice balance where
I have some people that I work with,
but I do most of the things myself.
So I have actually some I know what's happening in my life.
I manage my own schedule.
And so we actually,
I think sort of mostly scheduled this.
Yeah it was just us.
In person.
Yeah, it was just us.
But I feel like when you're in that position
and you're on a television show, I mean,
on some level you need those people,
the incoming has to be just completely dizzying.
So there's no way that you'd be able to manage it
on your own.
Oh yeah you become a big machine.
If you're successful,
you become a lot of moving parts
and then you become like sort
of the Millennium Falcon or something.
But now you're living on a farm outside Austin.
Yeah.
Is it in Bastrop?
Yeah outside of Austin.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you're like Ryan Holiday's neighbor now.
I am yeah.
I was texting with him yesterday, in fact.
Are you really?
So that's hilarious.
That's so interesting.
How has the, how does it feel,
like there's this sense that there's this great migration
to Austin right now?
Is that, do you feel that,
is that real or is that just like a handful of influencers
move there so it feels like more people than it actually is?
No, the inundation is real.
It's palpable.
You feel it for sure.
And already before the pandemic, there was,
an inordinate amount of people moving there every day
and then the pandemic hit and then a lot of people
and then all the like influencers
and all the people you recognize.
Right, and then I'm sure like a second wave of people
that want to be around those people.
Yes, yes.
And I, you know, honestly, I'm concerned.
I'm concerned because you know,
Austin's slogan is "Keep Austin weird,"
but there are a lot of people that just aren't that weird.
They're just like, you know, kinda
kind of typical and they're coming in
and they're not passing through
that rite of passage to keep Austin weird,
meaning like being a part of like that culture,
which is unique to Austin.
Yeah but not too many of those people
are going to be buying ranches or farms
and growing their own food unless they do fit that bill.
Yeah well the, you know, they're in Austin.
I skipped town almost, you know.
You're not even in the mix of that anyway.
Exactly.
Well, I'm really interested in this arc
that you've been on,
which kind of parallels this Viktor Frankl
"Man's Search for Meaning" kind of a hero's journey.
I think it's fascinating.
It's a recurring theme on this show,
but it's really my favorite kind of landscape to mine.
This exploration of how you go from achieving
your wildest fantasies as a young person
and living this overindulgent lifestyle
only to wake up one day and discover it ain't all that.
Yeah.
So why don't we go back to the genesis of that?
Okay.
I re watched
"Teenage Paparazzo" the other day.
And I also watched,
I had never seen the documentary that you made
about reconnecting with your dad, "A Shot in the Dark."
And I found it super interesting.
I mean, I think "Teenage Paparazzo"
feels almost quaint
compared to what's going on right now,
everybody with their flip phones,
although Facebook existed,
social media, wasn't what it is today.
And so it was sort of cute compared to
what it must be like now.
Had you been living kind of the life that you were living
in this particular moment.
It was totally simpler times.
Yeah, I know, right?
Yeah.
It was like celebrities were celebrities
and they were chased by the paparazzi
and the paparazzi were just trying to make a buck
and they were tabloids and you know,
they now it's just far more complex.
Right.
Yeah.
The "Teenage Paparazzo" movie for people
who haven't seen it,
you connect with this young kid who's,
out there shooting pictures of celebrities,
he's like 13 or something like that.
And he goes on his own kind of exploration of fame
as his notoriety increases in no small part
because of your interest in him.
He's gotta be like 25 now, though, right?
Have you stayed in touch with them?
Yeah.
The last time I ran into him was at some LA party,
but we don't talk much.
No, is he still doing that?
I think he's transitioned into more photography.
I mean, he's a talented kid.
So he's, I mean,
I don't know exactly to be honest,
but I've seen his Instagram and a lot of photographs
and pretty pictures.
Interesting.
In the documentary about your dad,
you get a glimpse of,
what your mom is like the era in which she grew up,
the circumstances under which you were born,
and looking at your life now,
it feels like you've become your mom's son.
Like she's this hippie,
all this spiritual, mystical stuff,
which is kind of much more in your wheelhouse now.
Well, you know, finally stopped rebelling
and decided to just embrace my nature.
Yeah, I suppose.
Instead of rebelling against my mom and trying to be,
not, don't tell me what to do or who to be
I'll decide myself.
And I realize there's a lot of wisdom
in what she was sharing with me,
what she was offering once I decided to just
stop being a rebel without a cause.
Yeah.
And ultimately I owe so much to my mother
and so much gratitude and appreciation
for the way she shaped my thinking
and my heart, mostly my heart, my spirit,
I'm so grateful to have grown up in a home
that was loving and as supportive as I did,
even though it was a single mom
and she was working really hard
and often absent in many ways because she was,
in the grind.
Not to say she wan absent mom,
she just was working so hard,
I didn't get a lot of her attention.
Yeah, she's busting her ass for you.
Busting her ass, exactly, exactly.
I mean, you know, you get that in the movie.
Like this woman is incredible
and the responsibility that she,
decided to shoulder for herself to create this life for you,
uprooting you from New Mexico and moving to New York City
and just being on the hustle to provide for you.
Yeah and also now an adult, finally,
I'm able to recognize that my mom
was operating within a larger culture that,
in which men were mostly absent.
Males were around,
but like men who like divine masculine men embodied men
who were showing up and providing that support system
and playing a positive role in the family,
it didn't exist.
It didn't exist for her, it didn't exist for her mother.
So, and I think in the movie, she says, she had a,
in a sort of a displaced sense of a role of a man.
And so that pattern carried out in her while raising me
where she didn't really have any men to support her,
so she took on that male role for me.
And that's actually been quite an inspiration for me today
now is how can I now be the kind of man that would show up
for my mother, for me as a kid,
and of course now for my partner and my future children.
Yeah and having to learn that
without having a strong male figure
in the household, when you grew up, I mean,
she says in the movie that after you reconnect with your dad
and you have a few simple moments with him
that you have actually received more love
than she received from her dad,
even though her dad was in the house
because he was so emotionally unavailable.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, and trying to part of that movie, although,
you know, on the surface,
it's kind of like this road trip to meet your dad,
beneath the surface,
it's really this exploration on your part
to try to understand what fatherhood is.
And this all takes place like a couple of years
before "Entourage" even happens.
Right, so you're grappling with this idea
of what it means to be a man
when you grew up without that presence in your life.
So it's not like a new,
this idea of what does it mean to stand tall and be,
you know, an emblematic, responsible,
loving, compassionate provider.
These are subjects that you've been thinking about
for a long time.
They've occupied a lot of space in your consciousness.
Absolutely.
I mean, I believe that,
I've come to this planet to wrestle with these themes
of manhood and father and all that stuff.
And it just keeps repeating itself
in different aspects of my life.
And I mean, if I had to make the,
I probably should remake that movie
because it has so many holes in it.
I was 20...
Yeah, you were so young.
I was 20.
I turned 21 while we were shooting that film
and I didn't know anything.
So I was,
it's a film from the perspective of a 21 year old kid
about what it means to be a man
or what fatherhood is having not had one,
not grown up with one.
Yeah, I should probably do the sequel.
I think it would be cool because yeah,
it's this time capsule, like what is a mind at that age?
Like what is the preoccupation and what interests you
and what problem are you trying to solve,
but to figure that out as a mature adult now
with everything that you've gone through and experienced
and all the growth that you've experienced,
I think you could create like a sequel to that.
That could be powerful.
Mm-hmm yeah.
I think it's, what would we call it though?
I don't know.
That title comes later.
Yeah.
I don't know what to say about that.
I mean, it's strange because
I'm practicing so much
in just the being part and not the telling part.
You know, for a long time,
I was spending a lot of time performing,
look it, look it, I got it all figured out.
And I have a lot to say,
and now I am much more interested in just head down,
chop wood, carry water, and just be present
in my daily practice really of being
that embodied man.
And I haven't quite, as I said,
I was in mostly isolation and now I'm just coming out.
It's like, how do I tell my story?
Even this is awkward for me
because I haven't had a lot of interviews
over the past couple of years.
And especially to talk about something so personal.
So I'm trying to find where that balance is
between the beingness
and then telling and communicating them to others.
And when that compulsion arises to express yourself
or to tell a story, or to tell people
the way it is that coming from an egoistic place?
Is that coming from an older version of you
or is there something more pure like,
and figuring out how to parse those two things?
Yeah, well, I mean,
I got lost in the business of acting and filmmaking,
where I was trying to climb that ladder
and always maneuvering to put myself in a position
where I could get that next role
or make that next buck.
So that could always be expanding and growing
and lost track of the art of expression
and the reason why I initially was drawn to filmmaking
was to be vulnerable and to share something of myself.
Yeah not entirely,
but more and more the money gigs
started taking precedent over,
the meaningful gigs and that's-
But that the nature of the business.
Yeah, I mean, it did start that way.
You were kind of this punk artists kid
who was all about purity and integrity,
you went to LaGuardia high right.
Like, it was just like the fame school,
did some acting there went to college for a stint
and kind of became an actor
because you had a facility for it,
but it was mostly a way to fund
these other artistic endeavors and interests that you had.
I mean, in many ways it was my ticket out of the hood.
You know, I was like living pretty meager means.
And I didn't want to have to, I wanted,
I wanted more, I wanted all the,
I wanted the financial security, I wanted
the cool parties and all that.
So that was the easiest route for me.
Yeah so just,
I had the talent and I had people that were prompting me
and asking me to come audition and do stuff.
So I had a lot of people that were wanting that of me.
But my sense was that you would take these roles
to kind of pay the bills,
but the heart was really somewhere else.
I tried to make that work.
I tried to sit in sort of this artistic integrity
while I still like, Robin,
this is Robin Peter to pay Paul type thing.
Like, I'd go in,
I make a couple bucks in Hollywood
and I'd come back and try and do real art.
And spend all my money on-
And you were in bands
and you were documentary and stuff like that.
And then "Entourage", like, you know,
everything goes out the window.
Yeah I said, Robin Peter to pay Paul,
but I meant like Robin Hood, that's what I meant.
That was like the Robin Hood mentality.
I get these money from the fat cats
and I'll put it to a more.
(laughs)
And in many ways I'm still still in that trip.
Aren't we all on some level?
I mean this podcast is supported by sponsors
and I love my sponsors.
Yeah thank you sponsors.
But we live in a a commercial world.
And to some extent we have to play by those rules,
if we want to function and,
share what we're here to share.
Yes, yes.
Well, we think so.
We've been told that that's the only way
that we can structure.
Our civilization.
So help me re-imagine,
help me re-imagine this.
Yeah well, that's what I've been doing now in my life
is focusing on the role of money and investments
and how we actually build a civilization
that serves not only humans, but also the environment,
sort of a more holistic approach to investing.
So I started an impact investment company that has,
a certain philosophy,
a certain approach to investing that is novel,
it's sort of it works within a capitalist system,
but it also seeks not just ROI return on investment,
but also YBM, we call is yields beyond money.
You know, the things that are intangible, things that are,
you know, perhaps create meaning in our lives,
the things that are in harmony with,
and interconnected with our natural systems.
And so that's really what I've been focusing on,
because I do believe that our economic system is a story
that we built and we told,
and it's worked for us thus far, but, you know,
if you look around,
it's just not working the way you thought it would.
And we need to, I think,
reinvent how we exchange value with one another
and what it is that we're focusing on creating
'cause money, capitalism,
incentivizes certain,
the creation of certain types of businesses
and certain types of material things
that are on many levels, just not serving us anymore.
Yeah.
Well it promulgates a zero sum perspective on everything
and it prioritizes quarterly gains
over the long-term interest of individuals in the planet.
That's right.
I mean could go on a long rant about that.
And on some fundamental level,
like from a Yuval Noah Harari perspective,
like the entire structure,
the system of money and commerce is built on a story
of social contract that is actually just illusion.
We think of corporations as entities,
but it's a couple of pieces of paper
and it's a collection of individuals and people.
So how can we create a new story that's in better service
to all of our interests.
And I think the cynical would say, well, look,
you're still a venture capitalist.
You're investing in these companies,
you're operating within the system and you can call it
a conscious capitalism or whatever you want,
but are you not just doing the same thing?
And how do you create a tangible, like metric around,
yields beyond money?
Hmm yeah.
Well, it's a challenge, right?
And I judge whether or not we're on the right track,
based on the amount of resistance we get
and sort of calibrating
the resistance.
You can't do that.
What?
Like you can't do that.
Exactly.
Like, oh, that's not possible.
Or when and I've been judging just the nervous systems
of people that I've approached with this concept,
and a lot of these guys have a lot of money,
enough to never worry again.
And yet, in those moments,
you feel their heartbeat race a little bit,
and their breath speed up
because the idea that they would be investing in something
that wasn't purely focused on ROI,
although we do pretty well anyway,
but really looking at the things that are intangible
and that's the scary part
is like the things 'cause we crave certainty.
So we want to see the numbers
and we want to make an investment
that's going to guarantee a certain return
so that we can have more dollars and cents in the bank,
more zeros and ones,
on the computer screen of our bank account
versus the things that are perhaps more important
or the things you can't calculate.
You can't, they're just beyond the edges of our calculators.
It's the human to human shared experience.
It's how we live in nature and connection and family
and community, and a state of being health, wellness,
mental health, sense of self, intelligence.
Like all these things you can't, calculate so easily.
And so it's a little bit more challenging,
but I do believe that we have a winning formula
if you want to get formulaic.
To actually bridge that gap between making fine returns ROI,
and also putting an emphasis on the yields
that are beyond money itself.
Because money in our current system is the focus is the goal
when money in our minds is not a goal,
to accumulate more and more and more,
it's the tool that we use to create the things
that we want to see in the world.
Or a by-product of something mission-based.
And by the way,
one of my favorites,
favorite ideas is you can't be rich
unless your neighbors are rich, right.
If you buy the nicest house, the biggest mansion,
the most beautiful, pristine piece of property,
and there are slums all around you, are you really wealthy?
You're going to have to build higher walls.
You're going to have to be more isolated,
but if you distributed that wealth,
or at least it was distributed naturally within a system
to as many people and everybody had a nice house,
then you could walk down the block for miles
and there'll be,
rolling fruit forests in people's yards
and people would be out playing
and it'd be a safe neighborhood and that's wealth.
You don't have to get locked up in your castle
because you're afraid for your life
or you're afraid to leave.
So I sorta, I apply that same philosophy.
I mean, is it great to have a lot of money
in your bank account?
I don't know.
I mean, it's just sitting there.
What's really great is to have the richness of life
that comes from spending your money in wise ways
so that the return is more connection, more friends,
more family, more health and wellness,
those things, experiences.
Yeah I think that's a very powerful statement.
And I think it's buttressed by the fact that
you tried it the other way.
Like you're coming from a place of experience with this.
It's one thing to say academically,
this may or may not be true,
but you lived a life of indulgence
I guess would be a fair enough word to say it.
I don't know how you would characterize it,
but you kind of had all that and deployed it
in a self-serving way as probably,
most young people in their twenties would,
only to discover that it left you feeling empty
and that the wealth that the kind of sense of wealth,
wealth being defined in a more broadly,
in a more broad context,
brings your life meaning by deploying resources,
to the benefit of others.
Yeah, it's the zero sum game versus the infinite game.
The world is infinitely abundant
because the limited definition of wealth,
when you spun your example of the mansion, I'm,
it's the slums.
As human beings we're kind of predisposed
to measure wealth only in comparison to others.
So if everybody, if you deploy that wealth
and you're living in a robust community
where everybody's needs are met, are you wealthy?
Yes in the broader definition.
In the limited definition, you're not
because your house is the same size as everybody else right?
Right.
And I'll just I'll make a celebrity analogy
that makes me laugh because I've been there.
I've experienced it.
So I would often get paid stupid amounts of money
to show up to a club.
Like I'll just I'll tell you, frankly,
that's what would happen.
They'd pay me a big check
so that I would show up to their clubs
so that their club would look cool.
Or the, they could say that I was there.
And so it would bring up the cool factor of the club.
I don't know why they hired me,
but some people think I'm pretty cool.
But anyway, they would take, they would raise basically.
Now I'm the product because they paid me
and they would place me in the VIP section
with the velvet ropes and the bouncers.
And I would be sitting there all by myself alone,
while everybody's out in the club dancing and having fun.
And I'm like.
You're a zoo animal.
Exactly, a totally zoo animal.
I want to be out there like dancing, having fun with people.
And so I would I'd tell bouncers like
I'm sitting there looking at their asses.
Like I'm sitting there looking at these big bouncers butts
and I'm like, guys, you know, I don't know.
It's cool you guys can go somewhere else,
remove the velvet ropes, remove the velvet ropes.
And then suddenly the commoners come in
and start hanging out in the VIP section.
And when you have people in the VIP section
that aren't in isolation and aren't up on like a pedestal,
suddenly the VIP section
looks a lot like the rest of the club.
And now it's.
You're happier, they're happier.
Right but the club owners,
they didn't get their money's worth
because now it's just another section
with people having fun,
as opposed to creating that mystique
and creating the separation,
which elevates me to this status where people can gawk and,
like taking pictures of zebras behind in a zoo.
The counter narrative is that,
look, if you come to this club,
you actually might get to hang out with this guy
as opposed to look at him past a rope.
Wouldn't that be more alarming, to their customers?
Well, once you start hanging out with me,
it's not that special.
So I, you know,.
But they can take the pap shot.
A lot of these celebrities need the velvet rope
because when you break down the facade,
it's like, they're just people.
It's like, not that interesting.
I'm a pretty good dancer.
But other than that, yeah.
Well, what's wild.
And I know you've told this story a million times,
but what's wild about the whole "Entourage" thing
is the meta nature of it all.
Because in so many ways,
it parallels this trajectory
that you went on in your personal life,
where the lines got incredibly blurred
between the character
you were portraying on television
and the way you were acquitting yourself
in your private life and kind of public life as you.
Yeah I mean, the lines are so blurred.
I can't even tell you what was, what, like.
When were you Vinny and when were you Adrian?
Well so acting is really just
tapping into the parts of yourself
that are true and honest to a character that's not you.
So just borrowing the peace.
'Cause we, you know,
we have all of it in us and we choose to be,
you choose to be rich at a certain age.
You decided this is how I'm going to behave.
And these are the patterns
that I'm going to express as rich.
And then me Adrian.
And, but we have all of it.
If you think about the time when you were in eighth grade
and you were going to high school and you're like, oh,
it's an opportunity for me to totally change my look,
and no one's gonna know no one's gonna call me out
as being a fraud or in authentic
because nobody knows me yet.
So you can actually change yourself.
So we have all of that within us and in acting,
that's what we do, right.
We find the parts within ourselves that can,
that are the villain that could do what that villain does
or the parts of ourselves that are romantic
and we can play that romantic part.
And at the end of the day, that's,
what was the question I'm sorry.
I don't even know what the question was.
The meta nature, the surreal nature
of playing that character and where you were living.
Exactly.
So when I got the role of Vince,
I said, no to that role.
You were like doing a documentary
in Mexico or something like that right?
I was still attempting to maintain my creative integrity
by doing a documentary about Cuban hip hop.
I was sneaking into Cuba
and I had a thousand dollars to my name.
I had a camera,
I was going to make that film.
And then I was like,
you know what?
I'll make money later.
In the meantime, I'll make a great film.
And then I get this offer for this show called "Entourage".
I read the script and I'm like,
this is the most superficial,
these are not the kind of values that I want to promote.
And I said, no.
And then they kept coming back to me and I was like,
I don't do TV.
It's not TV, it's HBO.
And no, I don't.
I, you know, I kept saying no, essentially.
And then finally,
I came to terms with the fact that if I didn't say yes,
eventually I was going to
Hollywood would turn its back on me entirely.
Your manager was going to fire you.
Right, yeah.
Just find a new manager.
And so I did end up taking the role and I had to, I mean,
I would say that I had the hardest time out of all the cast
and they're all fine actors,
but to play that part was so different
than who I was at the time.
And so it was not easy to become Vince
and the more I did it,
the more praise I would get from the directors and producers
and creators of the show,
and then the show comes out
and then now the fans start giving me thumbs up.
Then I would go out in the world
and people would expect they wanted me to be the character
because they're so familiar with it.
So I'd walk into a room and I would get instant approval
and then rewarded every time I showed up
in the Vince (indistinct).
So yeah, I started to indulge that
for the sake of the fans,
but also because I was parlaying that into other
opportunities and then suddenly the thing you're performing,
the thing you're pretending becomes you.
When you do it enough.
Right, the lines get incredibly blurred.
And I suspect the defense mechanisms come up
or the rationalizations like, well, yeah,
but at some point I'm going to get back to the documentaries
or what is the narrative that you're telling yourself
to justify the behavior.
Or does that just go out the window?
Well, yeah, look, I did make "Teenage Paparazzo"
at the height of my celebrity.
So I was still on some level maintaining my connection
to art and remaining grounded on some level,
which is, I think what allowed me to come back to earth now.
'Cause I had, I been, if I truly believed,
there's, you have to believe,
you have to allow yourself to believe that you're somehow
worthy of the attention and worthy.
Otherwise it feels so sociative.
Like you're just like not.
But there's a lot of actors
that don't feel worthy of that.
And that's what really creates the psychological dilemma.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it's a tricky thing because nobody really
is better than anyone else, right?
No, one's somehow, you know,
you and you have to make excuses for it.
And over time, over history, it happens with,
wealthy people or people somehow convince themselves
that they're better than other people.
And it's because if you're royalty is 'cause
your blood is different and you're somehow special
and there's this rationalization
that you somehow deserve all of the riches
and the spoils of this thing.
So you rationalize it so that you can keep having more of it
and taking more and taking more.
Because if you realize that,
somehow there's something amiss,
then you start coming down to earth
and you have to start letting it all go.
Right yeah.
Which is really hard.
I mean, you're in this for like a decade, right?
20 years.
So the constant approval and the feeding of the ego,
I mean over that extended period of time
has to really do a number on you.
And attention, attention is it's a drug of sorts.
It's humans crave attention.
We, you know, it's like a, you know, like a puppy,
you can pet them and in they'll like it,
but humans need like that approval,
that acknowledgement that,
the attention itself and in a media based culture
where all the attention goes to the few
that get clicked on,
the rest of us start to feel like,
who's looking out for me, you break down
the breakdown of communities and the family unit
and people are living in more isolation on their phones
and in technology
and in their little tiny one bedroom apartments.
So yeah, it's intoxicating to have all that attention.
You want more of it.
Yeah and yet, I mean, when I watched "Teenage Paparazzo,"
you had a significant level of self-awareness around it
to at least explore the meaning of it
because the real narrative of that movie is exploring
what fame is, what creates fame and what does it all mean?
Like going behind, the velvet rope of the media machine
to see how the sausage is made.
And when you kind of ingratiate yourself finally
into the paparazzi community and they accept you,
like you're not there to like,
put them on blast or anything like that.
I mean, it's pretty fascinating
that whole, like, kind of subculture and ecosystem.
That was such a fun movie to make it really was.
I got to infiltrate
the media machine from like the vantage of a celebrity.
I had a lot of access that another filmmaker wouldn't have
and to be able to use my position and take advantage of,
what I had accomplished an actor to make a film.
Nobody else.
The thing I'm proud of is nobody else
could have made that film because I don't think anybody else
would have made that film.
If you're famous, you don't want to rock the boat.
You know, you want to just like, okay, in fact,
a lot of the "Entourage" guys pulled me aside
and they're like, what are you doing with this film?
'Cause I was hanging out with Paris Hilton and like,
glimpsing into like her experience from her perspective.
And of course, when you hang out with Paris Hilton,
all the gossip, rags start writing about it.
Right.
They don't know-
You create your own.
It's so easily manipulated when you're like,
I'm going to go to Parises house,
and we're going to walk out together
and Austin's going to take our picture.
And then two days later it's going to be everywhere.
And then the opportunity to just indulge the meta-analysis
of that hall of mirrors, where we were creating the stories,
the paparazzi are taking the bait
and they're using those stories to generate
for their publications.
And then now we're making a film about that.
And then Austin little paparazzi is becoming, it was so.
It was becoming famous in the making of that,
like the metal layers of it, like just continue to unfold.
Yeah.
And now we are living in that exact meta reality
that fractured.
You know, the hall of mirrors
that I think that movie sort of preempted,
and you mentioned, we were early days, it was,
Instagram didn't exist.
It was.
Right it was all about those magazines.
The internet was a new thing that time.
Not nearly as relevant as they were then,
but now the phone is a hundred fold.
What those things kind of did to our brains.
Yeah and there are all these people
that have 41 million followers, and I'm like, who is that.
I've never heard of that person.
How could 41 million people know who this person is?
I've never heard of this person.
Exactly.
And I, there was, I think there was like a,
maybe a 32nd little edited clip
where we tip a hat to the coming technologies
is like, we just because they were new, like Twitter.
Yeah Twitter and Facebook,
like just literally a one second.
And then it was like, what's going to come next, all this.
And so.
Yeah, it just seems, it's a it seems so innocent now,
comparatively, I suppose.
Totally.
But it's the same thing.
It's just writ a little bit larger.
But to be in the mix of all of that,
for that long of a period of time
and having to kind of be part of that machine
while trying to maintain
some level of dignity and integrity,
like while you're getting paid tons of money and,
all the experiences that come with that.
Being, what were you like?
27, 28 years old.
Yeah.
That's when it really hit when it took off.
And so what was the interior experience
of the young Adrian
while you were in the midst of all of it?
Yeah I was, yeah.
I fancy myself, a spiritual person.
I was good person but in retrospect,
I made a lot of compromises to my soul,
my ethics in order to keep climbing,
keep getting to the next level.
I often see, and I was doing environmental work
and I was starting.
That's always been a part of who you are.
Like, I think there's this temptation
to look at that experience and say, you are off your path,
or you were on the wrong trajectory.
And I think you were on the correct trajectory
of the entire, like,
that those experiences needed to happen in order for you
to become the person you are today.
It's all, fine.
It's all good like.
Well, we want to be reductive.
We want to like, make it pat, you know, oh, you know,
you were on the wrong path.
Now you're on the right path.
It's, you know, it's messy.
Life is messy.
And I guess I like to think of it more as like not,
you know, binary, but more embodied
like are you more connected with your true nature
versus ignoring parts of yourself
in order to have this little ride
and the illusion of self, like, oh,
I'm this big Hollywood fancy guy,
as opposed to,
what's really going on deep down inside,
and what's your purpose here on this planet
to serve the world and to be,
to be of service to your neighbors.
That's how I see it now.
Yeah this wan experience that you had,
that was an expression of some aspect of who you are.
It taught you a lot,
you've learned lessons from it
and that's allowed you to mature and express yourself
in a different way.
And more importantly, I survived it.
Yeah
'cause a lot of people don't
'Cause a lot of people
got lucky yeah.
So I'm glad I survived it and came out the other side
so that I could,
bring the gold of that wisdom of the experience.
And then now share it.
So walk me through the process of kind of coming to terms
with that experience and wrestling with it,
reckoning with it to kind of motivate you
to find more meaning or go on this quest
towards greater self-actualization.
Yeah.
There's a predominant perspective,
I think in liberal culture that's yeah.
That thinks that somehow we can save the world that we have,
that we can save the environment.
You know, if the government's going to,
pay for all these services
that are going to help you out there,
I really come to terms with how important it is
that I take personal responsibility for myself.
And I take ownership of how I am
and how I show up.
I think Chris Marie said, it was like,
we heal the world when there's a transformation
of the individual.
And that mentality really struck home for me
because I was trying to save the world.
I was trying to make all this money,
do all this stuff to go out and proselytize
and tell everybody how they needed to behave
in order to help the oceans or do this, that and the other.
And I really did believe that I was a good guy.
I did all the right things.
I was look, I'm making all this money.
So like obviously I'm doing something right.
And then I started to chip away at that belief system.
And I started to look under the hood
and I realized there's so much that I was ignoring.
And a lot of the things that I was doing,
where it was hurting other people,
or wat least ignoring their experience for my own sake.
And I had to get clean and take responsibility
for what I was actually doing and get, I guess,
it's the awakening where you finally open your eyes\
and you realize what's actually happening
as opposed to just what you believe, what you're projecting,
what the fantasy of your life is.
And so the first step was opening my eyes
and seeing the harsh reality of what actually is,
what is not just what I'd been indulging.
Yeah, yeah there's this idea that,
well, I guess what I want to say is
the impact that you seek to have on the world
is calibrated to the extent to which you are embodying
that value system in your own self.
We can say, we're I'm trying to do this, that and the other,
but if you're living in a manner\
that's in congruent with that,
or you have yet to reach a certain level of maturity
where you're espousing those values,
where you can actually walk the talk,
it will, you may have some success with that,
but ultimately you're never gonna achieve
potential with that.
And it will ring somewhat shallow.
Yes.
So that awakening piece, like,
was there a specific moment or a bottom,
like I'm somebody who's been in recovery for a long time.
So I tend to like,
look at these things through that lens of,
kind of 12 step for an active shooter, but that idea of,
that low moment where it all comes crashing down
or was it a slow?
Yeah I actually got into the 12th step
philosophy, I guess, which has been very helpful to me.
I came to let you know, believe in God
through this process.
I started opening myself up to yeah.
I mean, for so long, I was so arrogant.
So in my head and yeah,
cynical and godless and nihilistic really ultimately
till I started embracing some of these frameworks,
12 steps an framework that has lot of wisdom,
a lot of this is very helpful.
Yeah and I guess there was this nine sense,
this sense of dread that something was,
bad was going to happen to me
because things were just too good.
You know, when you're high and like you're half asleep,
things feel very cozy and comfy,
but you're not able to actually see what's on the horizon,
but I felt something, and I didn't know what it was.
And I was like, things can't be this good forever can they?
Flying around the world,
going to all the parties, making all the money,
getting all the shows.
And then it, rock bottom hit suddenly.
And it was from like a totally unlikely place.
I was dating somebody
who basically in no uncertain words, said,
you are a horrible human being
and you need to take a big look at yourself,
I'm out and dumped me.
And I was so incensed and it was incredulous.
I was like, you're going to dump me.
Have you seen my house?
Have you seen my status?
Have you seen all the things that I've accomplished?
You're going to leave me.
I couldn't believe it.
And on the way out, she gave me a list of things to look at.
And I took that list and I was like, listen, I love you.
And I think you're out of your mind, this list is correct.
Like, none of this is me, this isn't, I,
I'm fine with all this stuff,
but because I love you and I respect you
I promise I will take a hard look at all this.
So after she left,
I took, I sat down and I started looking at the list
and slowly but surely,
I started to realize that she was right.
And that one after the other were things that I had
all that was
What was on the list?
(laughing)
Come on.
Well your relationship to sex,
your relationship to drugs and alcohol and escapism
and indulgences, chasing shiny objects, selfishness,
indulging in destructive patterns, that kind of stuff.
And I was like, what are you talking about?
I'm fine I got it all figured out.
Everything's great.
I do.
I'm a UN environment, Goodwill ambassador for Christ.
And I was like come on.
As long as you have that,
that it helps justify the other stuff.
Meanwhile, you're having fun
and your life is actually going well.
And the confirmation bias,
like everybody in the world's telling me, keep going.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
You're on the right path.
Keep making television shows.
I had this woman on the show yesterday
named Anna Lemke and she's a psychiatrist
and runs the Addiction Medicine Clinic at Stanford.
She's got this new book out called "Dopamine Nation."
that's about to come out.
And what's interesting about her thesis in this book,
she shows up in that documentary, social dilemma,
like the idea that
we need to look at addiction more broadly,
especially in this technological era
where everything is impulsing us in an addictive way.
But what I had never really kind of fully grasped
until I read this book was this idea.
And this is will come back to you,
that when we're in this relentless pursuit of pleasure
and you're somebody who is kind of living that
at a higher level,
that ultimately the pain that we've crafted our lives
to so desperately avoid, will slingshot back,
in great proportion to the extent
to which we're trying to avoid it right?
So that relentless pursuit of being just ahead of the FOMO,
and chasing the party and doing all the things
when you're in this perpetual state of dopamine inducement,
at a crazy level is not only unsustainable,
but is setting you up for this great fall.
Wow that's it?
Yeah, that's right.
We'll be back in a sec, but first,
if you dig this podcast and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy my latest book,
"Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from poignant essays by
and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast,
it's a gorgeous art full compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in
all wrapped in a hardcover coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website,
signed copies are available and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit RICHROLL.COM/VC
That's RICHROLL.COM/VC.
All right, let's get back into it.
So, boom, the woman leaves you.
Boom.
With the laundry list of character defects.
Yeah.
And I started a long road of going into the pain
and going into the suffering and all the things
deep down inside that I'd been avoiding
probably for 30 years since I was eight or younger,
all that childhood trauma that I was masking or floating,
just hovering just above and it hurts.
So of course you want to avoid it.
Of course it makes sense.
I was protecting myself from it,
but now at this stage in my life, I was like, okay,
let's look under the bed.
Let's look in the closet.
Let's see what boogie mans are there.
And hat was the process for doing that?
Well, first, I mean, it was just a long process of,
well first like getting advice,
asking for help, reading books, learning,
finally reading that book, "Iron John,"
that my mom gave me when I was,
when I was younger and I.
"Robert Bly."?
Yeah which I never read, like I don't the-
The EZOG and the whole kind of divine masculine space.
Like go out into the woods and bang on drums and stuff.
Connect with your beast,
connect to the beast within you become dangerous and then,
transcend that, but use it for good I guess,
but become embodied and become all,
the range to me, it's not about being good or bad
it's about coming to terms within,
in being in connection with all of the layers
of your nature.
So, but first I had to stop all the patterns,
all the escape patterns.
So I had to I aside a bit sell for some time,
I stopped drinking all the things that I would use,
all the tools I would use to escape all the dopamine fixes
that I had laying around and all over town.
Going on a dopamine fast of sorts.
I did a year of celibacy,
I mean, it was the most instructive in early sobriety
I did that and it was so regulatory
and it just puts this mirror up and you realize,
at least in my case,
like I realized how much of my behavior
was oriented around gaining female approval
and how fucked up my disposition was,
or my habits were around relating to the opposite sex.
A hundred percent.
I share that sentiment.
And all the things that come with it too.
The pornography and the way it shapes
your relationship to sex itself
and then the one, the biggest thing that really helped me
was recognizing that I had a deep hurt
because of what I'd been taught
at a younger age about sex,
and that was from this embodied men
or men who were dysfunctional or destructive
toxic, if you will.
Meaning that you should just be in pursuit of it,
or that it's a notch in your belt, or.
Yeah in the absence of having that divine masculine
role model growing up, there were a number of men who were,
who would teach me how to womanize, or how to lie,
or get away with things indulge in women,
as opposed to be in service of, or respect of
our counterparts.
And then men who were frankly inappropriate with me
sexually, who had
some pedophilia tendencies that,
I was around when I was a young age
and there's this one guy who used to tell me,
like dirty jokes when I was younger.
And I thought it was funny, but it can,
I realized at an older age, like, that's,
I excuse that kind of behavior,
because that's how it was trained, essentially.
I thought it was normal.
Yeah.
And you were desperate for
a male figure in your life I imagine.
Of course yeah.
Yeah.
And that gets imprinted.
Oh and then of course just not being there
for my father just bounced when I was younger, so that,
so I learned that how to escape, how to run yeah.
How to not be there.
It was interesting in the documentary when you meet him
and he, so, I mean the word passive is used,
but he's so bereft of emotional tools
to even know how to communicate properly.
And you relate your own kind of passivity with his,
but I just saw somebody who was extremely like,
just lacked any emotional aptitude whatsoever.
Yeah.
Sweet guy, you know,
but I think he sort of hides behind the sweetness
and he should read "Iron John"
you know, because we,
I believe there's a male frequency that is harsh.
And if you don't connect with that,
you let the world just throw you around.
Yeah.
Well, it's an interesting moment right now
in the conversation around masculinity,
I feel like masculinity has been
just lumped in with toxic masculinity as one thing.
And I know a big part of your journey
and what you talk about is a reclaiming
or a redefining of masculinity in a healthy context,
you can call it divine masculinity or any number of things.
But in this moment right now,
there's this sense that we need to be embarrassed as men,
or we're not allowed to be men,
or it's unclear what the appropriate role is
for a man because of the culture.
So we should just sort of step back.
And it's confusing as somebody who's a father also,
like, what is the role like, okay provider, protector,
but I also need to be emotionally available
and I need to be strong,
but I also need to be the guy
who goes to every school event.
And it becomes like it's much more complicated than it was
in the era of our parents or my parents
who are a little bit older than yours,
where it was little bit more binary
and that had its problems of course.
But I find oftentimes,
like I can't do all of these things all of the time.
Right?
Yeah.
It's hard.
I don't know if it has to be that hard though.
If you're the way I see it,
heart-centered, masculine energy leads like your values
and the direction that you're oriented to
comes from your ethics, your heart,
your love for your family, protecting the world,
protecting people, doing the right thing.
That's where your direction comes from.
And then it's all the other parts of you a man,
I find like the beast in me that helps me go execute
and go make it so,
and to protect, yes, I have to,
I have to learn to be dangerous.
In fact, like when I didn't,
when I wasn't in touch with my ability to be destructive
when I was almost, you know, in many ways,
emasculated by a sort of a feminist ideology
where no one like culturally,
no one wanted me to be dangerous
so they made me, they emasculated that part of me.
And then I became more dangerous
because all of that came out in shadow.
And I started doing things
that were subconsciously destructive.
And I wasn't stepping into that beast part of me
to actually protect and serve women and my community.
And so I feel like you have to be in touch with that,
but like be oriented from the heart space.
As an actor, that's sort of traditionally conjured as
a feminine expression, right?
It's a more feminine energy to be an artist,
to be a musician.
Those things would be associated,
at that end of the spectrum.
On some level I feel like
the conversation around divine masculinity
has an inherent femininity to it
because you're saying we need to learn how to connect
with the heart,
which is not traditionally a masculine attribute.
We're both.
Of course we're all, we're an amalgam of these energies.
So first we have to recognize the inherent femininity
within all of us as males.
Yeah I think maybe back in the day,
if things were more binary and simple
in which men attempted to be so masculine,
that it was just like undeniable that you were a man,
you had to prove it so much
that you lost touch of the subtlety
and the dynamic within ourselves.
But now I find myself to be ready really even leveled,
still very much in touch with my feminine.
And yet I've started to cultivate in fashion,
the more edgier masculine parts of myself
to really bring myself into balance.
And what does that look like.
Like how have you done that?
Well, I now live on a farm,
so plenty of-
Hands are in the soil.
Hands in the soil.
Using my body and my hands and working my muscles
and lifting heavy things and building things
and wanting to protect my kingdom and setting it up
so that there's a safe space for people to come and be,
for my family to live in.
Yeah.
So much of this in addition to being,
in this period of time where,
so many young people grow up without dads,
we're also in a culture in which we've been
robbed of traditional rites of passage
that teach us how to become heart-centered men
in so many ways.
And a result,
it's no surprise that you see these movements out there
of men congregating trying to recapture
some aspect of that or to create that for themselves
later in life in their own lives.
And I think that that's also why you see all these,
whether it's Spartan or like all these challenges
or running a marathon it's because-
Sports.
We don't have what we used to have as tribal cultures
that would put us through the ringer
and teach us what it means to do something hard.
And the confidence that comes with that
and the kind of acceptance that you would receive
within the tribal community for passing those rights.
Yeah, absolutely.
You know, as our culture expands and becomes more spread out
throughout the world, it's harder and harder to have that,
that those intimate rites of passage that is,
are passed down.
So when we have these sort of,
placeholder or these alternatives,
which are standards yeah.
Stand-ins for,
for that sports teams and all that kind of stuff.
I personally have been doing a lot of men's work,
working with other men
to bring each other through these rites of passage.
And it's been so important, so helpful.
And what are those experiences like,
like therapeutic or more like tactile?
Lifesaving just enriching,
just feel so blessed to have the kinds of men
that I do in my life too, which I never had.
You know, I never had brothers.
I never had those parental role models,
male parental role models.
But now I do through my brothers and now I'm an adult.
I'm a man.
I now can start to work on being that role model for others,
but to have other men to model things for me
and to push against me and to hold me accountable,
iron sharpens iron so there's a lot of,
the masculine energy wants to have that pushback
and that the wrestling or the horseplay
is so important.
And then the desire, the philosophical impetus
to make the world a better place.
I used to hang out with people who wasn't really interested
in making the world a better place,
or just where's the next fix, or
where's the next good time, a lot of Machiavellian,
how can I get mine?
And how can I exploit the situation to make more money,
or get more fame, or get more things.
Now, the men that I surround myself with
want to lead the world into,
I guess, a better, more stable way of being, yeah.
It's great, man.
Yeah it's awesome.
How do we scale this up?
Yeah, we've talked about it because it's not fair.
It's like, how can you be rich if your neighbors,
you can't be rich unless your neighbors are rich.
You can't be fully divine masculine
if your neighbors aren't.
We have to do this on mass, like at scale.
And there's not one size fits all,
but I would encourage everybody to seek groups,
seek local groups that meet in person to wrestle with this.
'Cause there's not one formula,
but it's just showing up.
And that's the most important lesson that I've learned
from my men's groups.
There's not one thing you're supposed to learn
except just to show up.
Don't retreat, don't dip because we all,
all of us in the group have,
and we've all shared this,
that we all have imposter syndrome.
Like, why do I belong here?
This sense of belonging, like, oh,
all these men are amazing.
Who am I to be here with these incredible humans?
And they all feel the same way,
and everybody is wrestling with the self-doubt
or the insecurity.
And so we just remind ourselves, just keep showing up,
just keep being vulnerable and keep opening yourself.
Because when you do it helps the group
and we help each other.
So I would just say, do you out there.
If you are seeking more, you want more from life and from,
you want to be, you want to improve yourself.
And as Christian Merde says,
transform the individual and go find others
and do that together.
But all you really have to do is just show up.
And be honest.
That's the big piece.
And I think a lot of men,
really struggle with the ability to
summon the courage to be vulnerable,
especially amongst other men.
But by creating a safe space
in order for that to be communicated.
I think the benefits of that, can't be overstated.
I mean, this is something I learned immediately in 12 step,
and I of course get a lot of that out of men's groups
that I go to in that context.
But I also have another men's group
that I meet with once a week.
And it's like,
seven guys it's mediated by a therapist,
been doing it for coming up on three years now.
Nice.
And it's just been unbelievable.
And that's not an addiction based one.
That's just, we get together.
Here's what's going on with me.
What's going on with you.
We mutually support each other.
And now we know each other so well, that we can,
we know everybody's blind spots,
or we've seen the patterns like you keep doing this thing
and you say, you're not going to do it
and then you've done it again.
Or we give the feedback
and the person doesn't take the feedback,
and then we have to deal with the problem
in the aftermath of it.
And it's just been amazing, you know?
And it's something that I think again,
to like look to camera, like, if you're out there,
this is something you can do in your own community
with your friends.
Maybe you get a therapist involved or somebody else
who has some level of expertise,
but if you don't have access to that,
there's nothing stopping you from getting
a group of dudes together to just talk in a safe space
where it's like, this is confidential.
But the intention is different than like getting together
with your friends and going out to a bar?
Of course.
Or getting with your friends and going out and like,
you know 4 wheels.
No, we're not going to watch the game
and it's not activity based like this is very focused.
Right, and that is maybe the challenge,
because we haven't been taught how to do that necessarily.
So I guess maybe not to oversimplify, it's like,
oh, just so easy.
Just go do it.
But, I guess it's important to just know that
it's getting together with other men,
specifically men and sitting in an allotted time
in a safe space where you communicate vulnerably
and it's very confidential
so that you can start to open up
some of the lower, the deeper layers
of what's going on inside that, get pushed down
because of the daily grind
or because of life takes precedent.
So how have you calibrated the growth for yourself?
Like when you think about what's important to you now
versus then can you gauge that
with some level of objectivity.
I'm in such a good place now.
I don't, dare I say, I'm not in an overt growth period.
I'm more in now,
let me take what I've learned and start applying it
in my life.
So that's what I'm doing.
You know, I spent the past two and a half years
with a lot of challenge and struggle and learning and growth
and shedding and rethinking everything.
And now, based on what I've learned,
I can go out and start to do, to build, to create.
So it's a really exciting time for me.
And I decided to express that by buying land in Texas
and building a community and doing a lot of the things
that I would tell other people to do.
Get in touch with nature,
connect with the land and grow your own food.
And while.
You're living in Brooklyn.
Exactly. yeah, exactly, exactly.
So, Yeah.
And it's I feel great.
And I'm starting to learn some of the skills
that I think my spirit craved building carpentry, you know,
I used to be, so I didn't want to be dirty.
It was like,
didn't like bugs and nature was scary.
And now I'm like dancing with it
and it's opened up a whole aspect of myself
that I it's just so it's grounding,
it's grounding is what it is.
And it's stable.
You're in a healthy relationship.
You've got this farm, you're growing food,
you got your permaculture certification.
I did I got my permaculture certification.
And that kind of thing of having your hands in the dirt
is the microcosm of the macrocosm conversation
about how can we live more in alignment with nature?
How can we create greater harmony,
not just with respect to the relationship with the land
and the foods that we eat,
but how we think about and practice commerce
and how we live our professional lives
and how we navigate relationships.
Like everything is a dance.
And it's all about like moving towards greater symbiosis.
Yeah.
And I get to express my unique perspective
of what that looks like in my little world.
And I get to be a laboratory for what's possible.
And I think we all need to on some level experiment
with new ways of being
in community and new ways of exchanging value,
that aren't what we're told.
It's not all about the stock market or dollars
and currency sometimes, there are other ways
that we can really start to support each other.
It's not all just pursuing the American dream,
which I think that's pretty much all
debunked at this point.
So this bit really exciting.
Right now, we're looking to invite people
to live with us as well on the land.
We have plenty of space to have a few people building
on that particular property.
And so we're exploring all the different ways
that we can structure the agreement amongst people
on how to live and share space
and share effort and contribute so that we can be additive
not extractive from nature itself.
So nature focused,
nature centered and nature being a shareholder,
within the community.
It's inspirational.
But I also like
the kind of knee jerk that I have in my mind is
we've been trying to figure this out for a long time.
Every time there's some communal experiment,
personalities get involved and it ends up imploding.
It turns into, you know, wild, wild country
or some version of that, you know?
And so how do you avoid those pitfalls?
Like what can be learned from other experiments
in alternative living arrangements
to find a new perfected way of doing it that is harmonious.
And I think that's exactly the right questioning.
That's the right line of questioning because
it hasn't worked.
Or maybe the ones that have worked,
we just don't hear about, because they're working.
It's always the ones that collapse
and have some sensational cult leader
and a bunch of Kool-Aid that we hear about.
So those stories strike the imagination,
our imagination, and they're fear-based.
I mean, Charles Manson or Jim Jones,
that's what you think of when you think Kamin.
Yeah obviously disaster, right.
Branch Davidian, they all, all the ones so.
Or scaled up communism.
Exactly, exactly.
So that's why I believe that we need to,
we need to double down and do it more to try and solve
for some of those pitfalls that they fell into.
So that's something that I've been considering as well is,
how do you create it so that
there's not one cult of personality.
There's like one ego bankrolling,
the whole thing, you know?
So initially I was like, well,
I'll just bankroll the whole thing
and then everybody can come and,
do a barn raising.
And just like Amish or something, that's bullshit.
And you're the landed Gentry and you have serfs.
Exactly.
So I was like, okay,
that's not gonna work because now it's still my operation.
I'm the one who bankrolled it.
And there's a subconscious,
if not overt sense of me being there.
Is a power topic.
Exactly.
A power dynamic.
So one thing I've been exploring is, and this is all open.
Like we haven't defined it at all,
but what about taking the profit motive,
taking the money out of the equation, right?
So create a land trust.
You basically put the land into a trust
and that the land becomes at the top of the hierarchy.
So we all work for the land.
Of the surface of the land.
Exactly.
We all work to steward the natural environment
to be the most bountiful and beautiful it can be.
And so anyone who lives there agrees to put their focus
in life force into that.
And also, you know, exploring,
like alternative currencies, like Bitcoin, and.
That's right.
You called me when you were in Miami at the big conference.
Yeah.
Using those kinds of technologies
to create a hyper-local currency,
which is fully transparent.
So when people are living there,
I'm not trying to exploit you because I was first mover
on this piece of land
and now I get to live pretty well.
You're working your off to pay me, premium
again back to the, can't be rich,
unless your neighbors are rich.
Like, no, like, I don't want to make money off you.
I want to work with you to serve the land.
So if we, if you have full transparency,
then everybody knows what everything costs,
what you paid for what,
and there's no subterfuge or exploitation
of through the ignorance.
Right, right, right.
Yeah that transparency,
I feel I could solve a lot of those problems
where everybody's on a level playing field
and they can see exactly what's going on.
And on a small scale,
I feel like you can really do that well, you know.
The minute it gets big and you have,
tentacles of a machine or a system that you can't,
you don't have eyes on, it becomes more difficult to, right.
Yeah.
But you got to start somewhere.
Well, I think blockchain and cryptocurrency
and social contracts and all of that
provide this unprecedented opportunity
to play out experiments in a way
that we've never been able to do before.
100% yeah.
Well, I think we're in a great Renaissance of opportunity
for people to experiment and try things.
And I think
it's a positive thing if we do innovate,
not just in business,
but also in ways of communion with other people, you know,
because as our traditional institutions start to break down,
or maybe they're not as effective as they could be,
or they're not protecting the environment,
or they're not protecting poor people,
marginalized communities,
we need to step up and take personal responsibility.
And self-sufficiency becomes a premium.
Absolutely.
And there's no better way to health
than to take responsibility for where your food comes from
and what you're putting into your body.
Yeah, sure.
I saw a cartoon or like a meme the other day,
and it was a caricature of a guy talking to an animal
and he was like I'm so much smarter than you.
You're just, you just have this small brain
and the animal looked at him and said,
"You're the only animal that pays to live here."
(laughs)
That's so funny.
I never really thought about that.
You know, think about that.
So when you make the land,
the land is the boss here.
You're completely shifting perspective.
Like it's a whole different lens on the whole thing.
And what if we all, I mean,
it's obviously that's rooted in ancient traditions.
So you are, you like, you're like 8% native American, right.
12, something.
Like that, 12%.
Just under taxation.
Just underneath that.
Yeah.
Well, and, you know,
borrowing from all those traditional traditions.
So, because it's not defined as of yet,
we get to explore building our own unique little system
borrowing from those,
the wisdoms of our old traditions
and also new philosophies, new ideas new technologies.
That's, it that's really exciting to me.
And we can just see if it works.
If it doesn't evolve into some sort of weird cult, you know?
(laughs)
Keep me honest okay.
Keep me honest.
I will.
I think you're tiptoeing into co-leader status.
I mean, like I'm wearing the white pants.
I know you're halfway there.
You got like a nice thing around your neck.
You know, you could dial you up into that, right.
A phone antler so.
Get you and Russell brand and Jared LIDAR together.
And something could come out of that.
(laughing)
That was low man.
Oh no but all three of them,
all three of you beautiful men,
expressing themselves in interesting ways right now.
That's funny, but all leaders of,
alternative ways of thinking and being, I think,
in your own rights.
Yes.
Yeah, that's all I wanna say.
So you're in?
Yeah I'm in I want to come and spend some time
on the farm.
Come on up.
I'm actually going to be in Austin, I think,
in the fall or the winter.
So I'll let you know, but I think it's cool it's exciting.
And I think it's cool that you're seeking out,
like when you're with DuContra,
when you're looking at a perspective investment
and you're trying to establish like the level of impact
or innovation that a certain company,
has the potential to be like, what does that look like?
Like how do you make that decision
of getting involved?
So we have four verticals that we use to make decisions
about who we invest in.
And they're all reflective
of the conversation we've been having.
What we believe is like a winning combination of things
that we need to invest in and support
in order to make a better society.
And that's about better humans.
So a better humans make better decisions.
They make better businesses.
They make a better world.
So we have a vertical called human flourishing.
So tools, technologies, medicines
that help level up the human being.
So health wellness, mental health-
Plant medicines.
Plant medicines exactly.
So tools both new and ancient
that will help level people up.
That's one vertical.
So community communities like companies
that are seeking to solve for some of the disconnect
that we have in our society, the fractured communities.
So how do we bring people together
in really important and meaningful ways
so that they can do the work to build a better future?
What we consume and how.
So consumer goods, we call it, do consumer.
So better for the planet, better for you,
stuff that we buy, how we consume it,
supply chain, materials, health, and wellness.
What's the ingredients and stuff.
So those are, that's the, it's a consumer vertical,
and then finally looking at money itself.
So the future of finance rethinking money and how we use it
and investing in tools and devices and systems
that bring more equity and more access
to the world's wealth.
And of course, blockchain technologies, Bitcoin,
and that sort of thing is like right up there
in terms of the types of technologies
that we think will actually be disruptive in a positive way.
Yeah.
How do you reconcile the environmental footprint
of crypto right now with
your environmental work and sensibility,
obviously there's work to be done here
to kind of figure that part of the equation now.
Yeah.
You know, maybe it's something
that people haven't really truly fully recognized about me,
but I've been a moderate environmentalist
for a long time for potentially for my entire career,
as an environmentalist.
I don't look for one size fits all absolute panaceas
to solve the entire world,
all the environmental problems.
There are trade offs to everything that we do.
And so I think we together need to start to create systems
that first of all, recognize what those trade offs are,
are honest about them,
and then start to create systems that are better for people,
better for the planet.
But there's, I don't imagine that there's a moment in time
in which our footprint becomes zero.
Sure.
It's our footprint is always going to at least be
greater than zero because we are here
because we do create ways
but how can we create closed loop systems
and how can we create ways to help be regenerative
about how we live and breathe
and how we tread lightly on the planet.
So with regards to Bitcoin, it's an new technology.
And yes, it does have environmental challenges
because of its energy consumption.
But I think the net benefit of the technology to society
overall is going to be a positive
because while there may be some environmental challenges
currently that's going to ultimately get better and better,
because the incentive is for minors and Bitcoin
and Bitcoin as industry to find cheaper
and less energy intensive ways of mining.
And then at a certain point,
it will cap out 'cause you can't mow mine anymore.
So then it'll drop to essentially zero,
but ultimately the technology will help to spawn innovations
and support entrepreneurs and different new technologies
that will actually better the world ultimately
across all sectors, including energy.
So I think taking currencies away from a centralized place
and bringing it to as many people as possible
will actually create a lot more benefit for society at large
and the environment.
Yeah.
It's pretty fascinating.
I admit to knowing close to nothing about it,
but I feel like what I, from what I do now,
blockchain technology,
it just holds unbelievable potential to change our world
in ways we can't even fathom right now.
The most obvious being like the transparency
that comes with it,
the efficiencies that can be established with it
that will inherently reduce, consumption,
and waste and things like that.
But I feel like we've barely even begun to comprehend
what that technology is going to bring to all of us.
Well, we were just talking about it on like a small scale
at Konsungi on the ranch.
You know, if there's transparency,
you can't exploit your neighbors right?
Right.
You can't mark it up higher.
But when, when there's so much murky transparency that,
suddenly and everything.
You create whatever story you want to create
that serves your agenda.
And you overpay for things and you under-deliver,
and then all money,
all finances are flowing through a centralized system
that are taking pieces without adding value.
So it's just highly inefficient
and allows for a lot of exploitation.
And when you have one-to-one direct exchange of value
where it's fully transparent, it's going to be so much,
I think, more productive in the long run for industry,
for business for just the way we interact and share value.
What's going on with the environmental work
that you're doing.
I saw, I mean, you were at a beach cleanup yesterday
and I saw the video
that you made about detergent thoughts.
Oh yeah.
So I didn't know.
I know.
I just assumed that that dissolves
and that was figured out.
So explain that a little bit.
So trade-offs right.
You know, like yeah.
You know, I've been playing in the world of trade-offs
ever since I've been doing environmental work,
as you recognize that.
Even environmentalist are flying around the world
to try and save the world and burning in fossil fuels.
So we got to give ourselves a break
and allow ourselves to think a little bit more
open-minded about what solution really means.
Is it about, we are now saved and solved
or is it about deepening our relationship
to the way in which we consume,
the way in which we show up
and just be more in touch with what those externalities look
like, and then take own own that own,
that you've done something that has detriment
and maybe correct for it.
But these pods, I believed like you,
I was like, ah, solution, right?
'Cause they dissolve and you can't see them to,
to the naked eye the environment is safe,
but on a microscopic level, it's just plastic
that's become melted and then dissolved into water.
So it's like a plastic goop in your laundry
that then goes into directly into the waste stream
and into the oceans ultimately or through,
your water treatment plant,
which doesn't have the technology to actually address
that particular substance.
And it doesn't break down.
and the biggest-
That should be illegal.
That's crazy.
Right.
And now we're getting into like centralized government
and they should have centralized government come in
and tell you all this stuff that you need to do, you know,
or can we together open our eyes and start recognizing that,
a lot of these companies are,
they're greenwashing or at least they're,
there seducing us into a false sense of security
when there are better solutions.
And that's one thing at Du Contra what we're doing.
You know, we're looking, we're really doing the deep dive.
You know, we're not just investing, oh,
it says it's green and it seems green
and we're going to invest in it
so we feel good about it
and we project an air of impact.
No, we're actually looking at the realities
of what those trade-offs are and recognizing,
hey, we're going to invest in this,
even though it's not a perfect solution,
but we see it a step towards a better solution,
or it's a better trade off than the one we have.
So we take our deep dives very seriously before we invest.
And when we found Blueland, I was,
I mean a great solution to these pod problems.
And I didn't know myself that they were,
these plastic pods were actually plastic.
And so Blueland came along.
It was like much better solution.
Yes.
So there are a detergent company that's figured that out.
Yeah.
So they do cleaning products,
home cleaning products,
they do soaps and detergents and all natural ingredients
and no plastic, zero plastic.
They just sell,
they're basically, I heard something that's like,
kind of like an Altoid for your laundry.
It's like compressed tablet
that you throw into your laundry,
or then you throw one of those compressed tablets
into a reusable jar for hand soap or,
all purpose cleaners and stuff like that.
Yeah, sure.
The greenwashing thing is out of control
and layer on top of that,
the fact that we live in a post-fact world
and a culture that isn't just so resistant
to embracing nuance,
like you're talking about the trade-offs
like everything has trade offs
and that's true in the environmental movement.
That's true in politics.
That's true in everything,
but we're now in this culture where everything is binary
bad, good, right, wrong, et cetera.
Anybody who's tried to engineer a product
and do it in a sustainable conscious way,
understands how complicated it quickly gets.
Like, well, we could use this ingredient,
which is better than this one,
but it comes from Vietnam.
And so we're going to have to ship it from there.
And this box is not plastic, it's cardboard,
but it's going to cost more or it uses this die,
which isn't great.
You know, it just quickly becomes,
a thing where you're chasing your tail.
And if you want to do it,
so that it's of the most pristine,
it's going to be priced out of the market
and no one will buy it and you'll go out of business.
And that's the reality.
Right, right.
It's like, everybody wants the purest,
most environmentally friendly product,
but no one will pay for it.
Right.
Just like everybody.
And then you're an elitist asshole
who's part of the problem because it's only available on
to be elite
Only you can afford it.
Exactly.
Or it's in, it's like our media diet too.
Everybody wants news with it's like has solid information
with news people that are-
As long as it lines up with your bias.
Well, no,
but I'm just saying that they don't want to pay for it.
So we let commercials pay for it
and then commercials drive the content.
Right exactly.
You know, 'cause if you want-
I feel like that's changing a little bit,
like you're seeing with sub stack
and everything that's going on.
Like people are finding ways to do subscription services.
Yeah.
But it's serving to also like bifurcate the markets so much,
like how many sub stacks are you going to subscribe to?
Well I think our society is just breaking down
into smaller, more manageable pieces.
You know?
I don't think that's necessarily a bad thing.
No, I mean, there is no monoculture anymore.
Is that good or bad.
I don't know.
Like there's all the globalization concept
that we're all going to be one big same governing body.
We're all planets onto ourselves.
You know, the idea of a television show
that would reach as many people as "Entourage"
is almost impossible.
Oh yeah, yeah, exactly.
Maybe that's good.
I can't, I think it's good.
I mean, how can you argue with evolution?
I mean, it's doing its thing and we're part of it
and get on board.
Is it evolution or is it devolution.
Well, yeah.
Sometimes I'm not sure.
It's both.
It's expanding, contracting, expanding, contracting,
breaking apart, rebuilding.
Are you optimistic?
I am.
I'm very optimistic.
So explain that to me.
Well, because I've let go of the ego part of me
that thinks I know the way the world should be
and surrendered to the playfulness and the joy
of just being a part of this existence where alive
that's, how can you not be optimistic?
We're here.
It's incredible.
I'm just going to let that sit for a minute.
I appreciate that.
I find myself vacillating between being inspired
and being despondent with what I see.
And a lot of that is fueled by me,
opening up my phone and scrolling through a bunch of stuff
and seeing some street in Germany
that where cars are getting pushed down the road
in a massive flood.
And I just think like, we're never going to figure this out.
Oh wait, did you think you're going to live forever?
No.
Oh.
But meaning as parent,
also it changes when you're a parent.
'Cause you think about the world
that your kids are inheriting.
Well, I do think we live forever.
Maybe that's the difference.
I believe that life is infinite
and ever transmuting and changing and transforming.
It's not ever the way you it's going to be.
Even if you have the best projections
and the best predictions about
what tomorrow's going to look like,
it's always going to be a little bit different.
So I think let go
with the healthy amount of ease, your expectations.
And so I live my every day,
not for how I imagined this world
in my lifetime is going to be, but more for how I believe,
like future generations should be living.
And I believe that.
That's back to Krishna Marty.
The idea of being the physical, mental, emotional,
spiritual embodiment of the person who's carrying
a certain resonance that you would like the world to embody.
It's really the only path forward.
I mean, that has roots in Zen also.
Yes.
The way to change the world is to change yourself.
Does that work for you?
Yeah, that works for me.
No, I'm completely on that page.
I'm completely on that page.
And when I,
when you're talking about we live forever
is that life about-
Life continues.
Life continues certainly.
But does your consciousness is transmuted
into something else?
Yeah, I mean you.
Or the oneness of consciousness,
the your portion of that oneness
then will find its way into some other expression.
We crave the continuity of self.
Like I'm the same person I was yesterday that I am today
and know you trust me because you can rely on me being me.
But that's a very limited
that predisposes that anything is static ever.
Exactly which it's not.
And if you expand out to a larger timeline, you realize, oh,
you've been changing every single moment.
And you're not the same person you were last year.
Certainly not the same person you were at eight.
But I can also talk.
I can communicate through time and space
by connecting in with my inner child who I know so well.
And he actually speaks to me,
he gives me lots of wisdom and shares with me.
The things that I helped me be a better man,
a better father for not my inner child,
but for my future children.
So I believe there is continuity
in being able to actually connect into multiple timelines,
not just your past within yourself,
but also close your eyes,
like how you imagine you want to be
and where you orient your life so that you can embody
and be in the embodied
expression of that future potential.
And then let go of it.
'Cause you know,
you're part of a much more complex system.
We could go down a rabbit hole with this
because ultimately time is a mental construct, right?
So the idea of moving through time
or speaking to your inner child, or,
communicating with your future self on some level,
these things are all existing simultaneously,
are they not?
And so when that inner child
is percolating up, what is it saying to you?
What is he saying to you?
Does he expressing his needs
or telling you it's going to be okay.
Or what does that exchange look like?
Yeah, I think right now he's saying,
don't be a dushbag.
Like make the sacrifices to be there for your kids
so that they have a little bit easier time than you did.
So it's yeah.
It's a lesson really, of presence.
Be the present dad that you didn't have.
Yeah right, yeah.
And so kids are, are going to be a thing for you.
Yeah hundred percent.
Be the role model that I wish I'd had.
When you look back on this arc,
do you have regrets
or wish that you had done things differently
or I'm sure people say,
what's the advice you would give yourself?
I get that question a lot.
I never know how to answer it
because everything is unfolded perfectly.
All the pain that I've experienced and,
the difficult times that I've had,
weather have all crafted the person that I get to be today.
And I would never want to shortcut myself from that.
Well, it's also the devil that, you know, right.
I'd much rather take the existence
that I've already experienced
and I've already gone through and like, okay,
I'll take this 'cause it could be worse.
Yeah, yeah.
And are you completely done with acting
or what's your relationship with the craft?
I just changed my relationship
to what kind of roles I've taken.
I'm not acting for money.
In other words,
I'm not just taking jobs because they're going to pay me
a good amount of money.
It's more if the role resonates.
Some crazy, awesome role falls into your lap
with an unbelievable director.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's still a tether, like a,
maybe a thread to Hollywood.
Yeah, I absolutely, I mean, I, and I'm also,
as I mentioned, I'm getting back into the storytelling,
like how I'm going to show up in that capacity.
And it's not all Hollywood and movies,
but also I have a lot of,
a lot to say in documentary form and short form
and so podcasts or docuseries,
I plan on doing a lot of that stuff as well.
Right, do you have anything,
any projects you're thinking about
that you're willing to share about?
Yeah so I've been is a little bit premature,
but I'll share it.
I've been slowly building a channel,
which I call "Earth Speed"
Life, a lifestyle in the cadence of nature.
And that's essentially going to be my channel
for sharing stories from the land,
just what, my trials, my,
my challenges and my successes in building the community
and learning how to farm, learning, how to grow my own food.
All of those things that I think should be open-sourced.
And shared again as I use my life a laboratory
or an experiment for possibility,
I want to be able to share that open source so that
not only I can get feedback, like,
hey, don't do that you dummy,
it's so much easier if you do it this other way.
But also, maybe other people might be inspired
to try it themselves.
And I think the more people start to experiment and explore
growing food in their backyard,
in their front yards do away with the front lawn,
make some food,
I think we're going to have to share wisdom in that.
So you've been documenting that all along?
Yeah hearing, right.
Yeah that's cool.
Are you connected to Zach Bush, Dr Zach Bush?
Farmer's Footprint?
Not directly, but I listened to him often.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, he's, he's a good friend.
I mean, that's the first thing I thought.
Like, you should sync up with him.
Please.
'Cause all the work that he's doing in that very space
with regenerative farming and permaculture-
Where is he?
Yeah.
He's been living in Hawaii mostly,
but he's got a place in Sanitas as well.
And Farmer's Footprint is located in Encinitas,
but they're close with them.
I can make that connection easily.
I would love that.
You know, I really think the future,
at least in my, the way I see it
will be absolutely decentralized,
but you'll have little pockets of sanity,
little islands of cohesion,
all in interfacing connected, but autonomous
and that's what we're looking to contribute to
is that vision is our land will be
its own standalone system,
but we'll have a lot of back and forth and exchange of ideas
with other communities and other farms
and other operations around the world.
Yeah I think it's,
it's just like anything else you have to start in one place,
prove that it's possible before you can tackle
the larger problem and then share the process of
how that was built
to then create scalable solutions.
Because we're looking at a food system right now
that's so broken that's so deleterious environmentally
that creates all kinds of food injustice,
and a battery of problems that are making us sick
and depleting the planet.
And truly the only way forward is to find new regenerative,
scalable, sustainable solutions.
So as consumers, yes,
we can use our front lawns and do all of that.
But those are really just pilot projects
for how to create an environmental model
and an economic model for the modern day farmer
that will incentivize them to make that switch
and get out of there big agg
paradigm to create food that is actually going to be able
to feed the planet.
Yeah I would just push back a little bit
on the expectation is scalability.
And I think it's this weird thing that we all believe
that scalable solutions are the right solutions
or a business that can scale is the best business
that we can have.
There's something that you lose when things scale.
And as I was saying,
once a system grows to the point where
the tentacles are so long that you can't keep track,
it starts to become inefficient and often
the externalities and the destructiveness
can sort of get away from you.
So I don't know if we need scalable solutions.
I think we need 8 billion localized solutions
within each individual that doesn't scale,
but it's very unique and specific to where that person is
or where that community is.
So I think it's not just a consumer solution
to grow food in your front yard.
It's actually environment wide solution
with if everybody takes responsibility
for their own little patch of land,
and we stop farming out no pun intended our farm industry,
our agriculture industry to these big scaled businesses
that can't really take care of the environment
because once you have a certain number of animals
on a feed lot,
the system collapses 'cause you need diversity
within each of those systems.
So it has to be small and it has to be localized
and individualized, I believe.
Yeah, no, that's a point well taken.
I guess a part of where that comes from for me is,
somebody who's been,
I've been plant-based for 15 years,
but I'm under no illusion that the entire world
is going to get struck plant-based.
Like, there's, it's always going to be,
a smaller percentage of the population and likewise,
not everybody is going to start planting food
in their front yard.
You know, there's just a large percentage of the population
that either live in urban places
or it's not accessible for them,
or they're working three jobs.
But perhaps to your point,
there can at least be these community hubs
in every community.
And you localize the whole thing.
And it's sort of community owned and operated
in a way that creates a brand new paradigm
that does reconnect the members of that community
who don't have the wherewithal
to like plant their front yard or whatever to purchase.
Or instead of the local forever 21,
you have vertical farming in that, you know?
Yeah yeah.
In that building.
It's crazy.
I was in New York City the other week and I did,
and I love New York.
Like I have so much fun going back there.
I mean, I didn't grow up there,
but I get such a boost of like energy when I'm there.
And I did a podcast with Eric Adams
who's most likely going to be the next mayor.
And he's got a huge food food initiative.
He had a crazy health story
that's made him very interested and invested in
shifting the city's relationship with nutrition and schools
and hospitals, et cetera.
And I was like I said to him, like every rooftop in this,
in this city should have a garden.
Like, and he's like,
I'm all about it.
Like I, to the extent that a politician
within that framework can motivate that kind of change,
I'm not sanguine about,
but just to have the conversation
about the possibility of that.
Every urban environment should make use of vacant lots
and rooftops and vertical gardening.
Like there is a crazy viable future
if we can, Marshall, the political will and the resources
to make those things happen.
And I think most people want that.
Do they?
I don't know.
You were the optimist.
Well, no, I am the optimist.
I just think that people still believe in the old paradigm.
They're still attached to this.
But you have to show them,
you have to show them the way,
this is where the cult leader thing,
you still need the personality right?
You got the white cats.
Okay fine, I'll do it.
You're halfway there.
Fine, you talked me into it.
Take us across the goal line, Adrian.
Cool man.
Well, I think that's a good place
to land this plane for today.
Awesome.
How do you feel?
I feel great.
I'm glad that we got to do this.
Me too, man.
I think it's really inspiring what you're doing
and impressive that you've made this life pivot
and decided to put these values that you have to work
and in the forefront of the advocacy.
And I know you're in a gestation period,
but like all artists,
you have to live your life before you can create expression
out of those experiences.
And I have no doubt that at the appropriate time,
you will bring expression to that.
And I think that that will be impactful to many.
So I wish you luck.
I wish you well.
And I'm at your service.
Thanks my friend I appreciate it.
Cool.
So if people want to learn more about what you're up to,
DuContra, Lonely Whale,
all the stuff where's the best place to direct them?
So ducontra.ventures
and we're actively seeking investments
so if you want to invest in what we're doing
and take a look at the model, reach out to us, email us.
So the website is to ducontra.ventures
and then of course, Lonely Whales
my ocean conservation organization,
lonelywhale.org.
We have a number of really great projects and campaigns,
including Ocean Heroes Bootcamp my favorite
where we host 300 youngsters
from 30 different countries around the world
to do ocean work.
That's cool.
Yeah I'll just leave it at those two for now.
All right.
And at Adrian.
Oh at Adrienne-
All the places.
Yes on Insta.
Cool man.
Well, hopefully you'll come back and talk to me again, man.
I really enjoyed it.
Let's do it.
Next time we'll record at the ranch.
Yeah.
That'd be good.
Okay cool.
All right it's a date
and I'll expect you to be wearing full white.
Okay.
All right?
I will.
Cool feathers.
Peace by plants.
(upbeat music)